[Music]
we talked about the old roadmap for
money and the old roadmap was born
really out of the Industrial Revolution
it was born out of the sense that of the
Wild West of anything is possible of
manifest destiny of American
exceptionalism whatever you want to say
or you know you could go back even
further but to capitalism itself but the
the roadmap is growth is good more is
better
whoever dies with the most toys wins
it's a materialist road map and it's the
part of the road map is not only that
it's an empty world oh there were you
know people here before the white people
came no and you know animals and there
was a living there was already a living
mature society on this no no no it was
empty and then the other part of it the
one of the essential ingredients of it
that still people even if intellectually
they understand it they do not get it is
that in that roadmap the economy can
grow forever and the earth is like just
sort of a toy chest you know you just
keep reaching in there and pulling out
resources keep reaching in and pulling
out resources so the economy can grow
infinitely because the earth is an
infinite cornucopia of resources the
fact that matter is that the economy is
a fabrication our economy is a
fabrication a set of rules inside a
finite planet there's a way to measure
there's a way to measure the human
impact the impact of human consumption
on the earth it's called the ecological
footprint and they can measure every
little scintilla of you know my watch
and my eyeglass everything I have
everything we sit in everything we walk
around on they can measure that in terms
of the amount of the planet it took to
develop that so we have measured the
amount of planet we have and humans are
consuming more than the amount of planet
we have every year that can be
regenerated ever since 1986 you know
that to me that was that data about
overshoot has been a central feature of
my life
like when I learned that it was just
sort of one of those things that's
obvious like certainly we want to change
so so the old road map this idea that
the earth is a set of infinite resources
and the economy can harvest those
resources every which way from Sunday in
order to produce economic growth that's
fundamental and then it trickles down to
the human as more is better and part of
that is as the economy grew is
industrialization and permitted more
products to be produced with less human
labor there was a sort of a peaking out
of of consumption around the 1920s and
it became a problem like what are we
gonna do so
there's several ways to expand markets
one is you export and another is to
educate your citizens to want more than
they need and then you've got an
infinite way to you've got an infinite
market called the endless willingness of
people to buy into the story of Moore's
better and keep buying stuff so that is
the old road map growth is good more is
better game over
not talking about the context of our
lives the social context where fairness
is fairness is sort of like built into
us babies all come with that stamp on
them you know fairness is important and
so you cannot you cannot stretch
fairness and believe that there's no
breaking point
so so injustice aside environmental
integrity aside more as better growth is
good party on the new roadmap says that
there is something called enough and and
enough is not sort of like this
oppressive ceiling that you know okay
I've got enough and I can't have any
blur no enough is this sort of vibrant
vital place what we teach is an
awareness about the flow of money and
stuff in your life in light of your true
happiness and your sense of purpose and
values
that you are enough point having enough
is having everything you want to need to
have a life you love and full
self-expression with nothing in excess
it's not minimalism it's not less is
more because sometimes more is more but
it's that sweet spot it's the Goldilocks
point and and so enough for me is like
one of the absolute fulcrums between the
old roadmap for money and the new
roadmap for money and and our surveys of
people who followed this program confirm
again and again that once people start
to pay attention to the flow of money
and stuff in their lives in this way
their consumption drops by about 20 to
25 percent naturally because that's the
amount of unconsciousness that you have
in your spending so when you become
conscious that falls away many people
say they don't even know what these to
spend their money on they just Oh
surprise I'm spending less I don't know
how that happened I just paid attention
I just asked myself you know is this
purchase of something making me happy
[Music]